all right this one's different
okay he's going to do the back inward
Kushi cuz I'm on the inward okay so
answer some questions which way does his
inertia have to be going say it out loud
so the camera can hear you forward
forward okay so I can't stop from have
him go
backwards okay so his Center has to keep
going forward and and then which way
does he tilt back toward me away from me
or forward does he tilt back does he
tilt away forward or toward me toward me
cuz I'm the center of the circle okay
and then
uh what do if he if he goes towards me
where's his
way on his right leg or his left leg
left his left leg okay so when he comes
forward and I tilt and I stopped his
head cuz I tilted it towards
me can his left leg go forward no what
about his right yes so his right goes up
you see it goes up I'll hold you it goes
up that's what you're looking for this
position here and then here's where the
x pattern comes
in okay so you do this for example
exactly in C through hole and just this
is where the engine is this part goes
forward there it is right
there now you're going to do it with
this hand this hand does it all okay not
both hands this hand does it all there
it is there you guys see that so I'm not
doing
10 I'm not doing that
this hand takes his Center moves It
Forward boom
around
go I I want to feel when that leg comes
up that's when I enter
okay try it oh there it is
there boom around
[Music]
I I want to feel when that leg comes up
all right so I not going to enter behind
him I can't get
there I can do to bring him forward cuz
I want his Center to go
forward which way is my angle of
deflection
going to my left so which way does my
angle deviation have to has to go to the
right so I can't go up
here I go this
way the fight has to rotate so I can't
throw on the
180 I throw
here can you see that okay don't go like
this and
back fight rotate oh there
I okay try it again
this
way here's where I have try to come in
no so I move you the other way where
I it's moving you right
other hand's moving
you and I go the other
way then I just hold my
adhesions you have you can't do it here
you have to pass you then you can do it
when you do it you have to go here watch
this hand now okay this hand's going to
do what it always does this this shape
this shape this shape hold my wrist is
eal
okay P don't pull you have to do this
shape
so the quas has to
move qu has to open but you can't rotate
your hip the qu
opens and you're doing it back on the
other
side got p
okay try
it okay in this variation you're using
this hand we have variations where you
use this hand this hand does the whole
thing but we're not doing that we're
working on
this this this whole
hand that's the whole thing see just
like just like this upper arm is doing
the whole
thing so don't come here use this sound
you see he is not out of the way and now
you go like this this is different this
is way behind me you see and now this is
all y on y cuz you threw him into that
hand and now you got to
throw this hand does
everything boom forward around there's
nothing
there nothing but aiming a falling
body the other hand already did
it did
it then my is not challenged
and you kind enter and Bas this place
thanks You' said that
your
the the neck hand is doing what uh I'm
trying to not I'm trying to guide
forward feels I'm going too far or
something so I'm try not to graag into
me on that first so it's it's a spiral
not just a line but then it feels like
I'm going forward too far and then
somehow this the the other hand ends up
being behind me when I'm
um trying to get the N hand correct so
it's it's it isn't my issue but I don't
know where I
was supposed to be anyone got the answer
some of you have that same exact
problem yeah see this is like we often
think there's like a a architectural
problem and it's not there you can only
do so much with architecture then it has
to do with what's your
engine got it what's your engine because
you you can't something can have the
same exact architecture but the engine
is different and it will not function
the same okay so uh for example if we
don't have him finally displaced okay
and he's pulling it's not going to
matter to
me you get it okay why because you're
not using internal which one I yes the I
there's adhesion there okay it's not
that he's he's coming forward and I get
out of the way and then I try to pull
him right I try to pull him but you
think about
it when and this is what's happening
right you get out of the way and you go
like whoa that's a freaking lot why
would that
be uh why would that not be a young
young Clash you see or you're having
to right goes way past me no matter how
much I move or you're going to have to
change your angle you got to wait for
him to come off you he gets further the
back brake fall and then you start ining
on the 12 lines right or you have to use
this arm to do everything that you
up with this hand okay so you
have to adhere you're adhering in the
grip you adhering on the arm and the
same thing here on the neck so if you
pay attention what when we hit that turn
where I reconcile your forward energy
this hand probably feels like this to
you right right okay because that's
where it gets really
sticky it gets really sticky at that
point because that's where the Yong
value increases and so the the adhesion
is going to be that much more friction
base okay and that if you watch that
technique again slow it down I never
even touched them with this this other
hand this was all this hand okay all
right so that's where you need to go and
and you can't you're not going to get
that in this drill in this technique it
assumes you have that you have to get
that in the ike sets
Okay any other
questions you feel that trist cuz I can
feel like every freaking vein and artery
in your neck at that point
right it just
[Music]
goes okay R it all right try it so a
drill that address the I part okay so
he's going to be pulling he's pulling on
me so I have to ground the front foot
and my adhesion point is in his palm
don't try to do wrist wrist stuff okay
you know don't do that stuff just here
in then we go to the next adhesion on
his hand okay on on my hand uh when do
you think this hand can touch at the
center line at the right at that Center
Line so pull here's where they can touch
and then it carries it out to the Y L
okay again pull P he's pulling that
whole time meaning he doesn't just pull
there and now he stopped pulling he's
still pulling okay so home
H okay try it so just like I'm not going
to use wrist stuff here I'm in his palm
I'm moving the Palm same thing goes on
this hand you can't come on the inside
and do this ledge here you see you can't
do that you have to be over here on the
outside because that's where your angle
deflection is there's no angle
deflection over here here's where you
get
here so it's palm and then the side of
his body is moving forward the side of
his arm Palm side okay try it again okay
we'll still have him pull he's still
pulling okay I do the same thing
adhesion when it gets to the Jing that's
where this other hand can touch when do
you think I can touch his
neck when it gets to the Jing do you see
then the other half you you could put it
on there just don't dare use it I
wouldn't do it cuz really exposes me do
you see that you have to bring him past
you and here's where your hand now
touches it okay and we'll bring It
Forward again forward again where's how
far does he have to
go Sil he passes me you see that's where
he has to
go
so there everything brings him past me
to there
okay it looks just like he's pull he's
pushing that's what it should look like
okay try to you know the answer so when
he when he's pulling which foot's
grounding the front foot okay as I move
him past which foot is going to be
grounding now the back foot okay which
in this case is which of my feet the
left okay okay so that means the right
one is free to move the right one's free
to move I keep that same
adhesion keep that same ground
Vector boom right leg moves and I'm now
ad hearing not this easy way but here
from the side okay goes
around there we are
okay try without I don't want you to
throw just work it on that
part the whole class started with he's
going to go forward you're going to turn
his head and that come up because that's
the back inward toi okay so we're going
to take out that part I just want to get
to here okay so what's happening now is
you're doing Federation I you're going
here
me but that's not the shape you're
bringing his head down ahead of his
hips you see that's not the shape the
shape is that his hips aren't there so
in other words you're here you see that
the shape is not that
the shape is his hips are not there and
his head is here
okay what you're doing when you get to
there is you go here that and now you
try to do that
okay some of you are crunching him
you're
like this do this is dump the
shape what you do with the neon has to
do the shape so I can't make his head
move in front of his hips you see that I
cannot do that I have to get his hips to
move in front so watch you tell me what
you feel I don't know if they can see it
so first speak louder so the camera can
hear you the head's moving first the
head's moving first and which way is it
going so down you guys see that down on
the other one
the head's going up do you see what do
you think the head going down versus the
head going up does to the
center what closes and opens yeah do you
guys see that so when you're here like
that I know that my stance my stance is
going to go down but my hand can't
change the
shape my hand has to keep the shape
the shap of
him you
see when does it go down if you're
interested in this head when does it go
down that's our question let's watch
again okay head's going
down
down other one head goes up here's where
it goes down
you got it so how would you describe
that to yourself goes down
when it goes down
when
no after the hips have come through
after the hips have come through after
the hips have gone forward then the head
goes down okay on the other one the hips
have not come all right we got we had a
little technical malfunction there so
we'll film what we talking about at the
end of the previous clip and then we
conclude in the next clip there's two
versions one's wrong one's right one's
an external version that you have if you
use the external
engine the wrong version happens you
can't do the technique it's also not
Marshall aside from not being
energetically correct it's not Marshal
and then the other one is the right
version and so what I'm having people
focus in on is the head to hip Rel ship
in the external wrong
version because I can't touch his feet
because I have no internal skills when I
move the head when I step back the feet
follow the head I'm I'm linking okay and
now this technique does not work you got
to do this
stuff in the correct version because I
can touch his feet from here whether
he's going forward or whether he's
pulling back it doesn't matter I move
his whole body goes
forward not his head as I go out his
whole body goes
forward allowing for when does his head
go down when does his head come towards
the ground in the external engine the
head starts to come towards the ground
before his feet even move in the
internal version his head is actually
going up you felt as you heard Tristan
say it's going up to keep his Center
able to move forward once his Center
passes the head goes down after the
after the hips pass and so it doesn't go
down until it's going
back the other one he's still coming
forward and the head went
down on the other one his head won't go
down until he's going back he's looking
up he never looks down at the KN okay
and then we have the last
clip on this one the head is up then his
hips goes the head goes down what does
that do for me mechanically in terms of
tap remember that what's it do it rces
the
am okay so it reduces the amount of
force necessary to bring the head down
because why
because what Cal andrial forces are
adding to it yeah so the leg is going up
with the centrifugal force so I don't it
doesn't I don't have to
goom and then pick that
up I move his head which I can do from
an
adhesion when I'm external I can't touch
his feet from here and so when I move
his head it comes
down from here I can touch your
Center okay try it again